Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two. David P. I do want
to let people know. I came back from my week
off to eleven hundred on listen to voicemails.
1100. It's going to take some time to go through
them all. I did get a couple of voicemails
about a particularly deranged anti-vaccine bit
of propaganda. I'm going to play one of those
voicemails for you. This one is from Troy York,
who really has fallen for the anti-vax stuff. Take
a listen, see if you can even understand it, and
then I'll explain it and tell you what's going on.
Speaker 5: Mr President, I would like for,
you know, the NFL player would be coming this
at the age of 33 and dying. And most likely,
this has to do with him being forced. To take
the vaccination. And the number of people being
killed now. And dying after taking the vaccine.
Is untold because the media doesn't come through
pain that comes, but it must be in the hundreds
and thousands. And the American people are
not stupid. They know that these vaccines
and we can consume much of the population,
which is. A large chunk of the buildings, and
Speaker 1: so that that's you, you probably get
the point that's probably going to be enough.
So the NFL player Demaryius Thomas,
did pass away, and that's very tragic.
It had nothing to do with the COVID vaccine. As
far as there is any evidence whatsoever to be
presented and the way that this spreads is
unclear. But he had been having seizures for quite
a period of time. His cousin believes that he
died from a seizure or complication related to it,
and there's no reason at all to think that it had
to do with a vaccine. I don't even know if he was
vaccinated, but let's let's presume he was, as I
think most NFL players are at this point in time.
The way that this spreads is that initially it's
the opportunism of a young person who should be
the picture of health because he's a football
player has died and he was found dead. It wasn't
a murder. It wasn't a car accident. It was well,
he had been having seizures and he was found dead.
And we're still figuring out the cause of death.
So it's an opportunity to say young guy dies. No
explanation must be the vaccine that's number one.
Then in the news articles, it is accurately said
as of right now, the exact cause of death
is unclear. So you've got the opportunity
and then you have for what? For a conspiracy
theorist. The absence of evidence which starts
to be used as evidence. Remember, that's a key
to conspiracies, am and conspiratorial thinking.
If there is evidence for something you say, look,
here is evidence. If there is absence of evidence,
you say that absence is an opportunity to assert
my belief about an explanation in this case. We
don't yet have the official cause of death. And
so it's a vacuum into which the conspiracy can
be inserted. And then, of course, when all you
have is a hammer, everything looks like a nail.
And if you want to just attack vaccines,
any death in which there is an unexplained,
immediate cause of death, you say, well, it must
have been the vaccine. So that's like the cycle,
that's the cycle as it is. And of course,
there is no evidence whatsoever for it,
which is the most important thing to keep
in mind. But unfortunately, a lot of people
I I hadn't even heard about the fact that it was
being asserted that the vaccine was involved here.
I googled it. There's a ton of wacky people
making the assertion absent any evidence. We have
a fantastic bonus show for you today. I'm going
to tell you what I was up to during my break last
week. A lot of really interesting things to tell
people about. Make sure you are a member so that
you get the bonus show. Sign up at join Packman
dot com. I will again restate my offer to you
that if you sign up for a listen to the keywords
here, a new full price yearly membership for $60.
If you sign up and pay a dollar eighty for your
first month, you don't qualify. OK, this is
new for price yearly. We will send you a free
T-shirt of your choice. Just email info at David
Pakman dot com. After signing up, tell me
the T-shirt style, color and size you want,
as well as your mailing address. We'll get those
right out to you. We also are doing a January 1st
midterm kick off membership special. If you've
been thinking about signing up and waiting for
just the perfect time, everything has to align
for you to sign up this January 1st is a great
day to do. It will be doing a huge membership
special will be notifying everybody on our
newsletter by email on the morning of January 1st,
so just get on my newsletter mailing list at David
Pakman dot com. And then as a final reminder,
tomorrow we will be doing the rescheduled final
town hall of the Year. It'll be streaming live on
the Pacman Live YouTube channel. 6:00 p.m. Eastern
3:00 p.m. Pacific tomorrow, December 28th. Hope
to see all of you there, but for today, we will
talk to you on the bonus show and you can sign
up at Join Pacman Dot Com to get instant access.